[Music]
on this friday night team canada has a
ball
kicking out the competition in soccer
our newest gold medal
at the olympics the hopes the sport will
score
a boost no property is worth risking
lives fast moving infernos decimating bc
with residents resistant to leave and in
california
we have firefighters getting guns pulled
out on them battle at the border
we surpass the point of ridiculous a
long time ago the demands of thousands
of cvsa workers
now on job action and the evolving fight
against coven
different provinces mean different
[Music]
strategies
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight
bara nasser
julia grazo's family erupted when she
scored the match winner in a sudden
death shootout
giving canada its first gold in women's
olympic soccer
grosso made no mistake with a kick that
bounced right off the hand
of sweden's goalkeeper a dramatic and
unforgettable win
after back-to-back bronze medals good
evening and thank you for joining us it
was a nail-biting fight to the finish
with clutch performances from several
key players
veteran goalkeeper stephanie labbe
stopped four shots
and jesse fleming scored canada's only
goal in regulation time
to tie things up as crystal gomencing
reports it was a thrilling victory that
kept this country on
edge until the very end this was the
moment the energy
shifted in yokohama stadium a foul
wasn't called on the field but captain
christine sinclair
protested sending the referee to consult
the video for a moment
canadians from coast to coast to coast
held their breath
it was a penalty jessie fleming of
london ontario
lined up with the determination of the
team loaded in her right foot
she nailed it fleming's goal sent the
match into extra time
and then penalty kicks after five shots
each still no decision it all came down
to 20
year old julia grosso and she delivered
a dreamlike moment for her family glued
to the tv
back in british columbia i was a little
nerve-wracking but it went in
doesn't matter what
[Applause]
it's a victory the women have been
waiting years to savor
the canadian squad has the world's
all-time
leading scorer sinclair with 187
international goals they've won back to
back
olympic bronze medals but knew they
could achieve
more she texts us right after i mean
obviously she's just
in shock as well and excited i think
more for the fact that you know
for sinclair as well right to be able to
have the gold medal
she certainly deserves it it's a
historic victory this
is the first time the canadian women's
soccer team has won
olympic gold of the 22 players
three including jay riviere played in
pickering ontario when they were younger
so just tremendously proud of jaden i
know the journey that
and the work that she's put into to get
where she's at
so yeah honestly very emotional and i'm
not gonna lie at a tear in my eye at the
end of it
pride and emotion for the women's team
finally conquering their quest for gold
crystal commansing global news london
now it is widely expected this will be
the last games for legendary captain
christine sinclair
the 38 year old has competed in four
olympics over her 21-year career
winning three olympic medals and with
187
goals she is the world's all-time leader
for international goals scored
today was her 304th game for canada
and the biggest victory of her career
two-time u.s olympic gold medalist abby
wambach was one of the people that
sinclair said
had a real impact on her career and
pushed her to levels she didn't think
possible
well today wambach sent this emotional
message
sinky nobody deserves it more than you
sister
awesome congratulations to all of canada
all the players also all the players who
built
the program the charmaine hoopers the
tancredies
the sophie schmitz you guys are all a
part of this win i feel super emotional
for you
good job it was a big day for canada on
the podium
track star andre de grasse made history
as canada's most decorated male olympian
with the bronze in the four by 100 meter
relay
the 26 year old now has six medals half
of them from tokyo
mo ahmed won this country's first long
distance silver medal
with a second place finish in the men's
5 000 meter race
and evan dunphy was given a bronze medal
for his finish
in the men's 50 kilometer race walk a
bittersweet victory marking the end of
the event at the olympics
moving forward and here's a look at the
medal standings
china leads the pack with 36 gold medals
canada is in 12th with six
we have 22 total to british columbia now
where a wildfire exploded destroying
homes and businesses
the massive white rock lake fire burning
between vernon and kamloops jumped a
busy highway
and ripped through the community of
monte lake jules knox is at a roadblock
near the fire
jules how bad is it
it's very bad here officials are calling
it horrifying and
heartbreaking thousands of people have
been forced to
flee their homes in fact early late this
morning
another 600 property owners in the
okanagan were told to go home
to get their belongings and that they
had until one o'clock this afternoon
to get out fast-moving flames jumped the
highway yesterday evening
and regional district officials are
still waiting for confirmation on the
severity of the damage
but are fearful that much of the
community of monte lake has been
devastated
including the general store crews
continue to battle
gusting winds today as people from many
nearby communities remain out of their
homes i honestly don't have any
great hope that it's going to be there
when we let me get home
it's not good it's really devastating
yeah i think the hardest right now is
just the weight
it's stressful i can't say it enough
it's on the back of your mind all day
long and all night
we're also hearing that not everyone's
obeying the orders to leave what can you
tell us about that
that's right we're hearing that
firefighters were pulled from the front
lines to help assist in tactical
evacuations
public safety minister mike farnworth
says this fire presents a very
real and grave danger that escape routes
can be
cut off very quickly and that officials
are very disappointed that some people
chose to stay behind
and that it could have cost lives a
small group of people
found themselves being overrun by the
rapid advance of this fire
while our crews were able to get the
residents to safety
these brave firefighters very nearly
paid with their lives
this experience was traumatic for all
involved and should never
have happened barnworth says it is still
too early for any damage assessments but
it is expected to be
extensive and there are no reports of
any people missing at this point but
again
that could change pharah jules knox near
vernon bc thank you jules
a wildfire emergency is also playing out
in the western united states as the
dixie fire in northern california
is now the largest in the country it's
ripped through an area
larger than los angeles the wildfire is
burning
as a broader climate crisis plays out
and that includes
a record-setting drought with conditions
so severe
that some towns are having to truck in
water
jackson proskow reports greenville was
wiped out by one of the largest
fires in california history this
mountain town that dates back to the
gold rush is gone
there were a couple of towers of flame
twice as tall as the trees just
huge towers of flame at times the
so-called dixie fire was so
intense that firefighters were forced to
retreat for their own safety
i've been fighting fire for almost 25
years and this is the most extreme fire
behavior that i've ever been a part of
other nearby towns have been evacuated
some already reduced to ashes
residents can only wait and worry unsure
if there will be anything to return to
finally get allowed back in there and
it's either standing
or it's a pile of ash that's when it'll
hit us
firefighters are dealing with tender dry
conditions unpredictable winds
and frustrated homeowners wary of
leaving everything behind
we have firefighters getting guns pulled
out on them because people don't want to
evacuate
there are worrying signs it could get
much worse
65 percent of the western u.s is
experiencing extreme or exceptional
drought
in the tourist town of mendocino water
has become so scarce
restaurants are using portable toilets
to keep customers from flushing away
limited supplies
hotels are trucking in water just so
guests can shower
right now cost 600 dollars for 3 500
gallons
that's lasting us a week fire conditions
are now so dangerous that residents are
being told there will be no time to
second guess evacuation orders
wherever the wind blows this fire is
where it's going to go
in this unpredictable fire season the
only certainty is of more dangerous days
ahead
jackson frost go global news washington
we have breaking news tonight global
news has learned no charges will be laid
against the acting chief of the defense
staff admiral art mcdonald
over allegations of sexual misconduct
our mercedes stevenson is following the
developing details
mercedes what can you tell us
well farah the chief of the defense
staff admiral art mcdonald who stepped
aside in february amid allegations of
sexual misconduct
and an investigation into an alleged
sexual assault
is not going to be charged under the
criminal code of canada
or under the national defense act global
news
learned this earlier today from the
woman who came forward and told her
story
making these allegations to global news
back in
the early spring and late winter she
says that she feels like she has been
punched in the gut by this decision
that she's unfortunately not surprised
but that she believes
this is why victims of sexual misconduct
do not come forward in the canadian
armed forces
in a statement the canadian forces
national investigation service the
specialized military police who look
into this
say that they looked at the evidence and
there wasn't enough delay
charges now heather mcdonald the navy
lieutenant
who came forward in this case told us
that there was about 40 witnesses to
what happened
it took place 10 years ago and there was
a lot of alcohol involved
and she's deeply disappointed that it
seems that interviewing all these
witnesses
the police came to the conclusion that
they were not going to charge we have
asked
admiral art mcdonald to respond at this
point we have not
heard from him this evening he had
previously declined to comment because
the case was under
investigation the big question now
pharah is what this means for other
women in the forces
and also whether admiral mcdonald will
return as the chief of the defense staff
as we are about to head into a federal
election
mercedes stephenson in ottawa thank you
mercedes
nine thousand border services workers
take job action coming up what they're
calling for
and how the negotiations are going
beginning monday fully vaccinated u.s
travelers will be allowed to drive
across the border into canada for
pleasure trips
and this is the first time that's
happened since march of 2020
but there are fears of long delays at
crossings and that was already the case
today
canada border services agency employees
are staging a work to rule campaign
they haven't had a contract in three
years global's sean o'shea has an update
tonight
on the status of negotiations
with airports busier as canadians travel
more again lineups stand to get longer
still
as canada's border agents push for a new
contract we surpassed the point of
ridiculous a long time ago we're over
three years out
members of the customs and immigration
union vowed to slow down
commercial and personal travel at land
air and marine border crossings
we could expect to see some delays in
terms of some of the pronouncements that
they have made
and what we've planned for that is
making sure that we have as much staff
on hand
land crossings like the bridge between
detroit and windsor ontario
are key to trade between the u.s and
canada some truck drivers said
entering canada was slower friday
morning we are looking at disruptions in
almost all your stores
but more than the stores i'm worried
about disruptions of the vaccines
and as of monday fully vaccinated us
travelers will be able to drive across
the border for pleasure trips for the
first time in 17 months
border points are expected to be even
busier for canadians traveling now the
prospect of a slowdown coming home isn't
pleasant it's going to be tough to spend
like four or five hours to get into your
country the union says border agents are
underpaid compared to other law
enforcement officers
and they want better protection against
what they call a toxic workplace culture
cbsa is heavy handed with discipline
discrimination harassment that
absolutely has to be addressed
the union schedule then canceled press
conferences this afternoon
spokesperson for the treasury board of
canada told global news mediation
continued all through the night that the
government was at the bargaining table
and that it would not walk away so
it appears right now that those
negotiations are
continuing pharah okay sean o'shea at
toronto pearson airport thank you sean
united airlines is going to require all
u.s based employees to be vaccinated
against covid 19. it is the first major
american airline
to implement such a mandate united
airlines joins a growing number of u.s
companies telling its employees they
must be fully vaccinated by late october
any employee who refuses to show proof
of vaccination
risks being fired the u.s is struggling
with a surge in infections
the seven-day average of new reported
cases has jumped to more than 90 000 a
day
that's up from around 12 000 a month ago
cnn has fired three employees for going
into the office without being vaccinated
against covet 19.
the u.s media giant says vaccination is
mandatory for anyone reporting in the
field
working with other employees or going
into an office
and it has a zero tolerance policy on
the issue
it is one of the first examples of a u.s
firm firing staff for breaching
a company vaccination mandate still
ahead the patchwork of plans across
canada
to combat a fourth pandemic wave
the number of coven 19 cases across
canada has jumped
54 since last week today bc's top doctor
reintroduced health restrictions
in the central okanagan due to a spike
in infections
outdoor gatherings are limited again to
50 people and the number for indoor
gatherings have also been reduced
nightclubs and bars will be closed
unless they serve food
and people planning to visit the area
are being asked to
change their plans when it comes to
pandemic policies and reopening plans
each province has its own strategy
abigail beeman takes a look at what
could be in store
for the fall in the next few days
two more provinces will drop mass
mandates manitoba and newfoundland and
labrador
though individual businesses may choose
otherwise no shirt no shoes no service
i'm sure there will be some businesses
who adapt that for masks
and in that new space of individual
agency some already face
backlash quebec is moving ahead with a
vaccine passport but the bureaucracy was
not fast enough for this
gym owner tired of being put in this
ferrous wheel of europe and your clothes
he's only allowing fully vaccinated gym
clients and he wasn't expecting the
online hatred that followed
some are even threatening hoping that
this place gets burned to the ground
as it's that bad it breaks my heart
proof of vaccination or passports are
controversial
as much as a libertarian as you might be
the right to swing your fist ends at
somebody else's nose
more provinces are considering them
we're looking at all options
in my mind this is about getting us back
to a safe and normal society
many experts believe passports represent
the way forward plus
point to some evidence they help boost
vaccination rates the hope is that if we
can continue to also
increase the number of people who are
getting vaccinated on a daily basis
we should be able to avoid the broad
universal lockdown
while nationally cases are going up
mostly among the unvaccinated
fortunately severe illness trends are
still declining
so if our goal was to not overload
hospitals is focusing heavily on case
counts as important in this
new phase of the pandemic those are
lagging indicators the hospitalizations
and deaths
the leading indicators will be our
positivity rates and our cases
so we always have to be kind of vigilant
in watching that much attention is now
focused on watching our vaccination
rates and that second shot uptake is
slowing more than 30 percent of the
population older than 12
still doesn't have two shots with many
bracing for more outbreaks in
unvaccinated populations this fall
abigail beeman global news
ottawa golden goals next the future of
women's soccer
through the eyes of a trailblazing
canadian
returning now to our top story canada's
historic gold medal win
in women's soccer carrie sirwetnick is a
former member of the women's national
team and she is the first woman inducted
into canada's soccer hall of fame and
she now runs and coaches
her own soccer program for kids in
vancouver it is a pleasure to speak with
you carrie especially today
you've spent your career teaching girls
and women in soccer to dream big and we
know canada was cheering today but i'm
curious what was the moment like for you
it's such a proud moment for canada
right now it's unbelievable
and what really strikes me the most is
their ability to manifest because they
came in
with the goal to win a gold and i've
never heard that language from the
canadian women's soccer team before
what made the difference this time i'm
really proud of beb prieston to come in
first
you know like to come in new team uh
she's been the assistant in the past
but you know to come in and people would
have been judging her you know in the
performance and
um surely she's been the one who's who's
created
this this idea right that we're gonna
win gold we're changing
the color of the metal right and poof
you know it happened
you were the first woman inducted into
canada's soccer hall of fame you
inspired
countless women of christine sinclair's
generation 20 year old julia grosso who
scored the winning penalty for canada
she watched sinclair growing up
and won gold with her today i mean you
began this long journey
to gold what does it feel like for you
it felt emotional like wow this is
like incredible to see something that
started
you know during our time and has evolved
to
to this this moment right because you
have to imagine that we all had those
same dreams too
and when i was young kid it's like
soccer wasn't in the olympics and there
wasn't a world cup and so
it for me it was like oh
yeah why don't we have this why can't
girls play at a high level right and so
we've had to improve our entire lives
that
were good enough to play so every time
there's
you know a olympics or world cup it
sends a message to somebody
that they are one capable but they also
have
the the right to go and and go after
these
dreams so what's next for canadian
women's soccer now they have something
to
stand on i'm sure there's thousands of
girls around the country
right now begging their moms to play or
dads to play
soccer i'm sure there's someone sitting
there
you know wanting to win the next gold
medal for canada
this gives permission for more girls to
go out
and and play and
know that it's okay for them to do that
carrie sir what nick just a pleasure
speaking with you thank you
and that is global national for this
friday i'm farah nasser thank you for
spending part of your evening with us
we leave you tonight with a look at the
medal ceremony for canada's women's
soccer team
years of hard work and determination
leading to olympic
gold congratulations jeff semple will be
with you on the anchor desk tomorrow
until next
time take care of yourselves and each
[Music]
other
[Music]
you